هذا وكان المستشار في مكتب الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بودل ياك اكد ان بلاده
تعمل على اعاده التفعيل الممرات البحريه
المعتمده في اتفاق نقل الحبوب
نحن الان نناقش الامكانيات ونستعد لارسال
السفن التي ستحاول المرور عبر الممرات
البحريه في اطار الاتفاق القانوني الذي لا
يزال ساريا بالنسبه لنا مع الامم المتحده
وتركيا سنحاول اعاده تفعيل الممر المائي
ونعمل على هذا بالفعل بدات روسيا تدرك ان
البحر الاسود ليس بحرا داخليا لها وان
الوضع سيكون مؤلما جدا قالها الرئيس
الاوكراني بوضوح شديد اذا استمروا في
القصف فسوف ندمر الاسطول وبحلول نهايه
الحرب لن يكون لديهم اسطول البحر الاسود
غير معنى كذلك من ادسا مراسا جزيره عامر
لافي يبدا معك نور الدين في الدنيا ونبدا
باخر تطورات فيما يتعلق بمنطقه البحر
الاسود عمليه انذار روسيه وهناك ايضا
هجمات بالمسير على
بالقرود الروسيه ماذا في اخر التصريحات
والمواقف الروسيه لهم
نعم ايمان يمكن القول بان اهم حدث اليوم
هو هذا الاجراء الذي قامت به قوات الروسيه
خاصه القوات البحريه في البحر الاسود
ايقاف سفينه تفتيش هذه السفينه وكذلك
اطلاق هذه السفينه لاكمال مسيرها هنا يبدو
ان الروس روسيا تحاول ان ترسل رساله واضحه
للجانب الاوكراني خاصه فيما يتعلق بمساله
المعابر المائيه على مستوى البحر الاسود
هنا رساله واضحه بان هذا المسرع المائي
وهذا المجرى المائي هو بيد القوات الروسيه
ربما هذه هي الرساله العسكريه الاولى
الواضحه بالنسبه للجانب روسيا الجانب
الثاني بهذه الرساله بان اي محاوله للعوده
الى اتفاق تصدير الحبوب ربما لن يمر دون
وجود القوات الروسيه وهو الانتشار الواسع
للقوات الروسي في هذه المنطقه مراقبه
السفن وربما منع السفن لان احدى النقاط
التي تتحدث عنها روسيا وهي ان بعض السفن
التي كانت بعنوان حمل الحبوب كانت تحمل
اسلحه للجانب الاوكراني وبالتالي التفتيش
هي جزء من هذه الاستراتيجيه الان التي
بدات روسيا ويمكن القول بانه التطبيق
العملي للانسحاب السياسي لروسيا من
اتفاقيه الحبوب والرساله عسكريه كذلك
للجانب الاوكراني على ان المياه في مياه
البحر الاسود هي من تحت سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه لكن ايمان يبقى السؤال دائما
هل يبقى هذا البحر الاسود هو مامن بالنسبه
للقوات الروسيه وانتشار القطاع البحريه
الروسيه ربما هناك القراءه العسكريه تقول
بان الجانب الاوكراني بكل تاكيد لن يسمع
لن يترك الجانب الروسي يتحرك بسهوله في
هذه المياه وبالتالي ربما قد تتحرك بعض
الحركات وبعد العمليات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه بهذه المنطقه لذلك بدا هنا على
المستوى العسكري التركيز على مجموعه من
المناطق التي يمكن ان تشكل مبدا بتشكيل
تهديد القوات الروسيه في البحر الاسود
وهنا الحديث بالدرجه الاولى عن جزيره
زميلي او ما يعرف بجزيره الثعبان وعن بعض
المواقع في اوديسا لذلك يبدو ان الجانب
العسكري الروسي ياخذ هذه المناطق بعين
الاعتبار وربما قد تكون محطه هدف للعمليات
العسكريه المقبله للقوات الروسيه لاطلاق
يد الاسطول الروسي في هذه المنطقه لكن
ايمان هذا التحرك العسكري على مستوى البحر
الاسود كذلك ربما يقابله تهديد كبير تتعرض
له الاراضي الروسيا ونتحدث عن الحدود مع
خركيم الحدود مع سموم وجود دخول طائرات
مسيره الى بيلدرود فبالتالي هناك تهديد
ويبدو ان الجانب الروسي يتعامل مع التهديد
بالتهديد المضاد وهي ضرب هذه المواقع التي
تشكل تهديد للقوات الروسيه وفرض امر
الواقع على الجانب الاوكراني